- You guys practice something you call
stoke activism, right? What is that?
- Well, basically stoke activism.
Our main mission is to bring bummer levels
down to a zero. We
believe. Yeah, we believe
that if we can eradicate all bummer
then world peace can be achieved.
- Nicely said.
- Yeah
- Yeah. And then someone
made us hip to the reality
that the government is
actually responsible
for a lot of city, state
and nationwide. Bummer.
So yeah, we go into city council meetings
and just try to hold them accountable.
- Okay. When was the
last time you were stoked
or when was the last time
you felt this kind of chill?
Cause I'm obsessed with
this kind of chill.
- I'm so un bummed right now. Like
I am the most un bummed.
Just like your presence
is like un bumming me out.
So like. I'm so stoked
- I feel pretty good
about life right now too.
Yeah. I did before you came in
but I definitely feel even better now.
I feel like you have a really
good energy. I like it.
- Thank you.
- So wait, do you remember
the first time that
you decided to get politically active?
- I do.
I was nine years old. I
was in elementary school
and the school was trying to do a
sign seating for lunch.
But I felt that was
incredibly draconian
cause that was the only
period of the day where
we had any sort of agency
in who we were kicking it with.
So I came in one morning
and I chained myself
to a lunch table and I sat there in the
sweltering heat for nine hours
but I didn't sweat cause
I was cool with purpose.
- Cool with purpose. I love this
- So Margret what would you like
to see Chad and JT advocate for?
- I think that your whole, like, you know
just trying to stoke
it up, like just stoke
us all up and keep us from being bummed
is so inspiring. I think this
is really, really important.
So I would just like you
to continue your work.
- All right
- Thank, Thank you.
- Yes.
- Thank you for the vote of confidence.
- Yeah. Yes
- Yeah. I love you guys so much.
So, wait, you guys have done some singing
at council meetings as well, right?
Oh look, you sat up.
Yeah. Like, yes, we have.
What is that like, What, what made you
break out into song?
Did the spirit move you?
- Yeah, I mean, I think words are powerful
but music goes the farthest, the fastest.
It transcends division,
it uplifts the soul.
And even if the song
lyrics don't directly apply
to the cause we're speaking on
it unifies the room. It
brings everyone together
like everyone wants to participate.
- What was the song you
broke out though at the
city council meeting? Do you remember?
- I first sang Toxic by Britney Spears
- Which is kind of
funny. The message, Yeah.
- We wanted the city of Manhattan Beach
to construct a toxic
water treatment center
in homage to her, but then it turned
out they don't have a
water treatment center
- So that's tough. Yeah. Yeah.
The, the more you know
though, the more we learn.
Yeah, I get it.
All right. You can see their show.
Chad and JT go deep on Netflix.